what a night van look at this the first
big red carpet back my man can you
believe it so
we're back the crowd was electrifying
i think the world is so
amped and ready and i'm just
proud to be just a small part of it all
and
ah it's very exciting i feel like the
world is opening up
i have to tell you charlize says she has
on a version of your triple x coat
tonight
that's what she said i love her right so
she says we love
her and her cypher character is one of
the best so good
you know cardi we didn't get to talk
about cardi b the other day but she's
made it to the franchise it was such a
great scene
please tell me that we're going to get
to continue a little bit of her
storyline
yes they are we are very much excited
to evolve her character and to expand it
into the finale she made it just in time
she came in past nine just in time
yeah justin said she's been there the
whole time this is just the first time
we're seeing her she's been around
that's very true i love it that's very
very true
okay last question i've seen the movie
you know that we got to talk about that
post
credit scene we see jason statham
don't walk away
you know like i said
the finale is coming
nine aligns starts to align
everything perfectly for the
greatest finale in cinematic history
come on now
i'm gonna give you a drop the mic moment
on that one all right
it's good to see you